today I'm going to show you how to play
let it go by a passenger now the first
thing you'll need is your capo I I
actually play with my caper at fret 4
and I'm going to play it in the key of C
because those are the chords that I just
most recently taught you
passenger actually plays the song in the
same key sort of the same shapes in the
key of C but he doesn't put it on K
before he puts it all the way up at capo
5 6 7 so instead of sounding like like
this which is my vocal range so that's
what he plays it in if you if your vocal
range if it's that or if you want to
play along with original that's where
you want to put your capo and what the
interesting things is because we're
playing the chord shapes in the key of C
as you may remember from earlier videos
when you put the capo on and you're
actually changing the key of the whole
guitar and you're making everything
higher so for instance if I just kept
playing my shapes in the core in the key
of C like so that's a C major but if I
put the capo on fret 2 that goes up 2
semitones so this is a D major and if I
put them up another 2 that's going to be
an E major now if I put them all the way
up to fret 7 which is where passenger
plays my key of C
actually becomes the key of G you might
wind up well if it's in the key of G why
not just play a regular G like so
it sounds pretty similar right there's
probably a couple reasons why passenger
does that part of it I think has to do
with the way he their finger picking
pattern that he uses and if you want to
learn that you there's tons of viewers
out there that will show you how to do
that but it also makes some of the
transitions between chords a bit easier
because some of the shapes in C are
easier to move between them shapes in G
somewhat harder so I'm it easier you'll
see in the video so let's have a go how
does the song start I think it starts
with the chorus yeah there's a really
soft course and it's just a finger
picking pattern but I'm not really
interested in that let me show you the
chords that it starts with so it begins
with an F I'll actually sing it for you
and and then I'll show you the chords
oh okay so there's two lines of the
chorus and they sort of repeat again
again what are the chords you go through
an F to a see this is my scene energy
base you might notice two G to an a
minor
then the line restart is very similar
back to an F
then a/c and then you hold on to the egg
and you don't go to the a mighty just
let this GP play for another measure
okay now a couple of things there
firstly the F because you're gonna have
to be changing from that F to the C
quite quick and there's a lot of fingers
to move so you might be having
difficulty with barcodes at the moment
you can still play the song quite well
if you play instead of a full F major
you can play what we call an F major
seven so instead of having this index
finger as the bar there leave the rest
of your three fingers there and instead
of playing a bar just let it play the
first fret on the second string sounds
like this it's not quite an F because
it's missing this F and this F those
notes which really belong in the chord
so you're just playing this trying to
avoid the that tongue sorry bottom
string there because it's an e which
doesn't really belong in the F chord but
that sounds not the same but as you're
playing quickly not even noticed and you
might also have seen that this shape is
very very very similar to the C with the
G bass that's the F major seven there
and all I have to do to turn into a C is
move these one two three fingers to
different strings same shape different
strings so you could play like that it
would sound like this well you only need
the
which is pretty possible why I don't
think it sounds quiet is good which is
why I play the F major but it'll
definitely work in a pinch and sometimes
the chords go so quickly if you're
playing with other instruments
particularly a bass guitar I'm you might
not even notice that the court is
different okay so that's the first
course at the beginning and then it
moves into the verse so let me sing the
sing a couple lines for you then I'll
show you the chords in slow motion so I
think it's
okay so very similar to the chorus which
is not a mistake you've got two lines
very close to each other
and they repeat over and over again so
it starts with the a minor into an F
open into a G day you'll make a dream
minor dreams come slow back to the a
minor and they go so f then to the G now
you might have noticed I play a little
funny thing here this is the if you
remember from the key of G that video
I'm gonna put in a G with a Jesus fall
and then you let go of the Jesus fall
back to a normal gene so they play it in
proper speed again and you can see it
so
so another thing to versed there that
Jesus for the
it's quite quick getting the ribbon down
for that is a bit tricky
you'll also notice I'm not really using
the pic to actually make that sound I'm
actually using this finger my index
finger to number one hammer on so that's
when you've got a string and you can
make it play another note just by
pushing your finger onto it with a lot
of force so like this so you might have
I'll do that again I'm only going to
strike the string once with the pick but
then I'm going to use my index finger to
push down to the string very quickly
which makes the second note see that so
that's quite a hammer on because your
finger is like a hammer pushing on to
the fret and then to go back to the
original G instead of playing another
note with my with my pick I'm actually
doing a what we call a pull off so it's
the opposite of a hammer on this is the
hammer on and the pull off is using my
index finger to pluck the string so you
can see I didn't even have the pick in
the area there so I'll do it again
hammer pull off okay so that this is how
it sounds
so minor differences if you miss that is
like that big a deal but if you listen
to the solar editor again you'll you
hear the the timing which he uses for
that and that's basically the way they
plays it okay now those two sets of
chords one for the course and one for
the verse are basically it there is that
bridge but that's I think it's pretty
much using the same chords as the verse
let me try
yeah that's exactly the same as the
verse okay
now just like in the chorus if you find
that F shake quite difficult to move to
you can replace it with an F major seven
so instead of sending like this we were
placing the F with the F major seven
sound like this
so this sounds pretty close the fmaj7
sounds kind of less complete a little
more hollow than the f major but like I
said it goes by quite quickly as a chord
and sometimes it sounds better to be
able to get to that chord quickly and
have it work with the rhythm rather than
have the exact right chord but not be
able to play it properly and therefore
muting strings and so on
and that's how you can play let it go by
passenger now one last thing before I go
I as you their song increases there's
differences intensity right so one of
the things you might notice is that when
he goes from finger picking to a fall on
strum so I I'm not doing the finger
picking pattern so I'll just strap it
I'll strum softer so see if you can hear
the difference between the verse which I
thought with into the chorus here so
let's see
see you when you close your eyes maybe
one day you'll understand why everything
you touch surely dies
- doh
Oh
you get the idea okay so you want to
have less strums during the verse let
the sound of the of each chord ring out
a little more rather than playing more
notes and don't strike the strings as
hard so there's a bit of a difference so
when you get to the chorus you can
really feel the intensity and the energy
of the song lift a little bit and that's
how to say that's how seeing let it go
by passenger